a grand jury indictment for Donald
Trump's alleged role in a hush money
payment to a porn star would kick off a
process in which the former president
would likely travel to Manhattan to face
charges Trump has denied wrongdoing in
the case saying the probe by the office
of the Manhattan district attorney Alvin
Bragg a Democrat is politically
motivated it's an absolute disgrace
what's going on we typically know how an
arrest happens where it happens and
exactly how a defendant will get from
the arrest to the arraignment but this
is a totally untypical situation here's
a look at the key locations where Trump
could be indicted arrested and arraigned
since late January a grand jury has been
hearing testimony from Witnesses in the
Lewis J lefkowitz State Office Building
at 80 Center Street these Witnesses have
been people who can talk about Trump's
role in the hush money payment to Stormy
Daniels hi everyone Witnesses have
included Michael Cohen who was Trump's
personal lawyer at the time and played a
key role in the payment and
reimbursement if jurors here vote to
indict Trump an arrest warrant would
then be filed under seal prosecutors
would notify Trump's lawyers of the
indictment and negotiate a time and date
for his surrender here in Manhattan
that's a common practice to negotiate a
surrender date with a defendant the
timeline here is really unknown
sometimes defendants appear the day
after an indictment is filed with the
judge and sometimes it could really be
several days or a week a defendant who
is allowed to surrender typically
reports to the Manhattan District
Attorney's office at one Hogan place
during an agreed upon date and time it
is typical for someone who commits an
alleged white collar crime time to be
handcuffed I remember we saw that with
Alan weisselberg who was the former
Trump organization CFO but with Trump
that's a something we really don't know
how that's going to play out if Trump
were to surrender and be arrested he
would likely have his fingerprints
scanned and his photograph taken for a
mug shot here after being processed
defendants are typically taken to a
holding cell in the Manhattan Criminal
Courthouse which is connected to the
district attorney's office but it has
its own entrances on Center Street
protests in the area around the
courthouse in recent days have sparked
security concerns Secret Service is
totally focused on keeping the president
safe but there's also a lot of security
concerns in terms of keeping Alvin Bragg
the district attorney safe
Secret Service agents would be with him
throughout the booking process and would
likely turn the courthouse into a
protective Zone and bring Trump through
a secure access point his safety is
their top priority during a court
appearance a judge would ask Trump to
enter a plea to the charges in the
indictment prosecutors and defense
attorneys could also talk about
ministerial matters which include
setting a date for the next court
appearance and exchanging evidence after
that he would exit the building and
presumably get back on his plane and
could be home in Florida for dinner
foreign
[Music]